[Music]
hey guys it's justine and today i am
showcasing this msi creator z16 laptop
for you a huge thank you to msi for
partnering with me on this video i'm
really excited to actually show you guys
this laptop because i am traveling right
now and it's been a while since i've
really had the opportunity to travel
with a laptop and be able to really
review it in sort of like a real-time
setting and this laptop has kind of been
my main device for doing all of my
emails for gaming for content
consumption and while we're here we've
been taking a ton of photos so i've been
using this a lot for photo editing and
one of the things that i have loved so
much about this is the display after
using a device that has a touch screen
like this you get so accustomed to that
and so used to it that whenever you
don't have a touch screen laptop it's
almost like i forget how to function so
having something like this that not only
has a high quality 120 hertz display but
it's also a touch screen is such a huge
win in my book this does have a 16 by 10
aspect ratio which gives it about 11
more viewing area with these thin bezels
it also has this 180 degree hinge so you
can actually lay the display completely
flat this is such a kind of a unique way
to use your laptop and i feel like it's
not something that is very common in a
lot of devices but it's so cool because
you can use this thing called flip share
so if me and my sister are working on a
project together or if you're working on
something with a co-worker or family
members or even just watching content
you can hit the flip share and it
basically flips your screen all the way
around so that they're able to see what
you're seeing this display also allows
for fast scrolling pinch to zoom and
more gestures with multi-touch functions
since i'm not at home i normally do have
multiple displays connected to any of my
laptops and this is no exception you can
actually use this with multiple displays
it does have two thunderbolt 4 ports
which will allow you to do that output
since this is a really powerful laptop
to be able to have it on the go but also
bring it back home and connect to
monitors is amazing because this will
give you so much more screen real estate
to do whatever it is that you need to
get done i've also noticed that the
colors on this display are really
incredible they're so vibrant and rich
and for me as a creator and also someone
who consumes a lot of content i want it
to be looking as vibrant and realistic
as possible it's using true pixel
display to deliver true to life images
with qhd plus resolution for more of
those vivid images that we love when
we're editing or watching content and
each one of these displays has been
calibrated in the factory and certified
the overall design of this is also
really beautiful it has rounded edges
it's made of cnc aluminum and it has a
laser etched logo and oh shoot i i
forgot to even mention this earlier but
the keyboard is one of my favorite
things this is the world's first mini
led rgb keyboard so this is going to be
giving you a brighter and more evenly
proportioned backlit keys and not just
in one color you have a full spectrum
rgb to basically make it any color you
want or multiple colors like this
beautiful rainbow keyboard i'm also kind
of curious to see how this stands up to
the 16 inch macbook which is something
that i have used for a pretty long time
to do all of my content and editing so
kind of looking at them side by side if
you are looking for an alternative to
the 16-inch macbook this could
potentially be one for you so here's
kind of the side-by-side specs of the
z16 and the macbook pro 16 inch i think
the biggest thing to note here is the
fact that yes this is a touch display
which i'm such a huge fan of i know i
keep reiterating how much i love having
a display that you can touch but it's
also 120 hertz refresh rate if you've
never really experienced 120 hertz
display before it's pretty incredible
especially for gaming the z16 also
supports wi-fi six whereas the macbook
is only wi-fi five with bluetooth 5.0
whereas the z16 has bluetooth 5.2 the
z16 has four speakers whereas the
macbook pro has two and while the
macbook 16 inch does have four
thunderbolt 3 ports the z16 has two
thunderbolt 4 plus two type a usb 3 and
a micro sd card slot obviously any sd
card slot is a huge win i honestly
mostly now use cf express cards but the
fact that this does have it a lot of the
drone footage that i've been shooting is
all on micro sd do have micro sd cards
in them so i'm able to pop those out and
put those right into the laptop so even
though i don't use them as much as i
used to the fact that this does have it
i'm definitely excited about it like i
mentioned before this does have the 180
lay flat display whereas the macbook
does it and i really love having this as
an option even if it's something that
i'm not using
just knowing that even if i accidentally
might push my laptop screen forward a
little bit too much it's not going to
get damaged because it's basically made
to lay flat as far as weights and sizing
the z16 is a little bit heavier and a
little bit larger i've been working so
much off of a 13-inch macbook so going
back to having one of these larger
displays has actually been so amazing
because i've missed having so much
screen real estate i'm able to see so
much more and again this 120 hertz
display looks so crisp when i'm playing
games definitely something that you can
easily get used to something else that i
noticed while using this laptop is their
attention to detail and obviously design
and aesthetic is something that is very
important to msi another example of this
is the sound on this thing it has a quad
speaker stereo sound system by dyna
audio and it's also using an ai acoustic
algorithm and it's using this real-time
intelligent engine to remove audible
distortions and vibrations without
degrading the sound and this is
something that it's really interesting
because i feel like when people start
talking about ai like what does this
actually mean and with devices like this
it is a laptop there's a lot of moving
parts and you're going to be moving it
from place to place so for ai to be able
to kind of sense what it should be
removing so that it's giving you the
best sound possible is kind of cool the
battery life on this is actually pretty
awesome as well it does have a 90 watt
hour battery with fast charging and this
is so key because i feel like a lot of
us not only are we always on the go but
even if we are just at home walking
around the house or moving our laptop
from place to place you might not
actually have an outlet that is easily
accessible all the time so to be able to
just plug this in get a fast charge
while i go get a snack and then unplug
it and go about my day and obviously now
traveling more getting back on planes or
heading out to coffee shops or going
back to meetings to be able to get that
fast quick charge so you can get on with
your day is definitely something that i
look for in a device now another thing
that i've been using this a lot for a
while i've been in hawaii is gaming now
i used to travel basically with a
console and it's great because now that
has changed so much because i can
basically have my laptop bring a
controller and still be able to play
games and in the middle of playing games
i realize i probably have some work to
do so i can just alt tab go into my
email do some work and then head back
into my game with my controller yeah i
do travel with a controller a lot of my
friends do my sister does as well so
this is definitely something that i
think we need to normalize in 2021 is
traveling with a controller well thank
you guys so much for watching i hope
that you guys enjoyed this video and
getting a chance to check out the
creator z16 laptop i'm going to put a
link in the description if you want to
check out the full spec sheet and get
any more information about it also while
supplies last they are offering this
limited edition a lessee wine opener
with purchase on select msi products
also put a link in the description where
you can find out how to redeem this with
your purchase thanks again for watching
don't forget to subscribe if you're new
here and be sure to hit the bell to be
notified when i post new videos and if
you have any questions about this laptop
or anything in general feel free to
leave them in the comments below i'll
see you guys later bye
[Music]
you